oh my goodness  we gave the kitties catnip  oh wow all right  they're having a roll off  yeah they're having a roll  oh  oh i feel like i should rate them like  at the olympics  8.5  look at you guys go  rolling so fun  [Laughter]  you guys are hilarious  where you going beijing you're going out  of frame you're just scooting all the  way over there  yeah  wow  [Laughter]  drugs are cool  [Applause]  damn  beijing  beijing's having a good time  don't you guys fight yeah they'll bust  that fight  [Music]  yeah they're already looking at each  other like  yes  oh yep  [Laughter]  yeah  good girl pook  don't let her pick on you like that i  know she's bigger  bigger and fluffier